fast forward to yesterday or the day
before
when Veritas dropped this third video
from Dr Walker uh I assume now formerly
Pfizer uh
uh direct worldwide director of mRNA
vaccine or mRNA strategies uh
in which he talks about the uh
hypothalamic pituitary gonadal axis
um that what he's basically saying there
is that Pfizer believes that the
menstrual irregularities are really kind
of the tip of the iceberg and that this
thing is damaging a fundamental aspect
of your endocrine system your endocrine
system controls your energy controls
your sex drive it controls all kinds of
development it controls your mental
state whether you're depressed or
excited or whatever it controls your
digestion I mean it's your endocrine
system is hugely important and uh it you
know endocrine abnormalities can be
associated with cardiac problems
uh and uh they can absolutely they are
absolutely endocrine fluctuations uh
impact on your immune function
so now now we have in addition to the
huge laundry list we already had of
potential causes you know in terms of
the pathophysiology for why we're seeing
these
uh immunologic suppression phenotypes
particularly the more people get jabbed
uh but now we have another one which is
the damage to the hypothalamic pituitary
uh adrenal axis
what's so fascinating about this beyond
the science that's obviously fascinating
is that you're sort of laying out the
story of your red pilling in essence
because every step of the way here
there's some Regulatory Commission or
some sort of censorious uh Outlet that's
that's kind of stopping you or that even
there you still are saying you had this
belief that the FDA would stop it so
when did when did you realize that it
sort of seemed like the entire Machinery
was either broken or my words just
outright negligent
uh
that's a that's a good question
um
as the
Adverse Events piled up
and and I I'm vaccine injured
uh I took the jab I took moderna when
the um uh National Guard was deploying
it here in Central Virginia
I was scheduled for a talk in France and
I knew I couldn't go if I didn't take
the Jab
and I had long covet and there was a
whole lot of press that long covet could
be could benefit from taking the jab we
now know that's a lie
um but uh you know more probably how
skeptical were you I mean knowing
knowing that you had had covet okay you
had long coveted but you had done
research I mean how skeptical were you
oh yeah so I I had number one
in good faith
I'd assumed that my colleagues that I
had known for decades
must have had
another part of the story that we didn't
cover is that Jill and I worked on this
tech for over a decade in Academia
in uh at California regional private
Research Center at bouse Labs at
um Maryland
uh and we abandon it because we could
never overcome the toxicity
and we have multiple other patents I
mean this wall behind me is all patents
um multiple other patents for different
candidac lipids uh different
formulations we published the first
stuff on use of cholesterol which is in
these formulations and uh early on I
called up uh the guy at um University of
British Columbia uh Peter Cullis who I'd
known for quite a while who was the one
that had really made the breakthroughs
to enable this uh this version that was
being deployed
and uh I had faith that they had solved
those problems that we had not been able
to solve
uh so
um I was still operating assuming that
that they had overcome the things that
had bedeviled us
that's a heck of a leap of faith huh
well I think it's reasonable I mean you
can assume that people are are nefarious
or you can assume that people are
generally good
and I prefer to assume that people are
although I gotta say the last three
years that's taken a pretty hard hit uh
yeah but I still I still approach the
world with an open heart I try hard to
and I and and I try hard to have faith
in my fellow man and um and I employ the
three strikes rule generally speaking uh
you know uh takes three strikes for me
to say I just don't want to deal with
that person again
um so so yeah I I
extended Trust
uh to my former colleagues
believing that they must have had the
Breakthrough that they asserted that
they had had
uh and uh obviously in retrospect
they had
convinced themselves as a as a community
of a number of things such as minor
modifications in the structure of the
positively charged fat would lead to
formulations which would Target specific
organ systems or tissues
and so they they had published and it
was believed in the field that these uh
modified versions and I we we in my lab
we built hundreds of different cadetic
lipid compounds and tested them at gen
sign they they tested thousands or tens
of thousands
uh when they were trying to get agents
to treat cystic fibrosis
so I I knew how the game was played and
and I the the literature suggested that
uh there'd been some kind of
serendipitous magic findings that if you
use this structure and you injected it
it would only go to the lymph nodes and
it would stay there and you'll recall
that's what we were all told
um and yet uh
that wasn't true it was clearly not true
based on the Pfizer data package that
Byron Bridal had obtained
uh so
you know when you're when you're in
you know you spent your whole career
working in an area
you have all these relationships with
people
uh professional relationships
to break out of that
and and say oh you know all these things
I thought were this way were wrong and
for me uh so I not only had that on kind
of a micro level in this little bubble
of this technology
but I think we've all had that those of
us that are awake have had that same
experience uh about our government uh
media
um uh military all you know uh
um globalism uh you know the I was our I
knew the World Health Organization was
corrupt as the day is long because I'd
been there a number of times and spoken
and dealt with them but
um but the scope of what we've been
dealing with I think for all of us
pretty much uh
we'd we just at least I had assumed that
uh the world was a very different place
and that people acted with Integrity
generally speaking
I wrote a a essay about this on substack
where I talked about
um
uh peeling off layers of naivete
uh and and I'm still not sure I've
peeled off all the layers of my night
I'm sure there's there's more to go but
there's there's always another layer
there's always another layer so so all
of this is happening and now you're
you're being red pilled because you're
seeing it through not only colleagues
but you're seeing it through the
regulatory commissions
myself okay I on jab two I developed
hypertension to 230 systolic and and
narcolepsy and restless leg and you know
all those at the time were not cataloged
as as Adverse Events but we now know
that they are
um so so I saw you uh I saw a clip of
you on Twitter a few weeks ago that no
longer exists but I saw it with my own
eyes so unless it was a deep fake I saw
it it was not from your account it was
from someone else's account where in
essence what you were saying was and
clean this up for me if I'm if I'm
getting it slightly wrong but that
basically some level of the MRNA vaccine
is sort of like a low-grade HIV in that
it is degrading people's immune systems
it's it's hitting the T cells so now
other dormant viruses are now popular
that was that's not a deep
um I don't know that I use the reference
to AIDS only if I did it would be a
reference to uh in autoimmune uh or I'm
sorry
deficiency syndrome
um yes you you made a point of of
differentiating between HIV and AIDS
yeah so uh acquired immunodeficiency
syndrome is the is what the and so if
you
do something you know you're in in a
state and then you then something
happens and you become more
immunodeficient you've acquired an
immunodeficiency syndrome right so
that's that's the tie-in it aids is
actually a big basket into which you can
throw all kinds of things
um
so uh
early on it just
as the clinical trials were still
progressing and then at the very
earliest time when they started
deploying this it became clear that
uh one of the adverse there was two in
particular that were popping up
that my buddies at the FDA who were
outside of the review branch
uh that I was having weekly zooms with
uh said we're being flagged and I was
hearing it popping up from other
Physicians
one was uh
myocarditis
which uh the FDA and the CDC denied
in the Israelis denied that's the story
uh and how that how that finally came uh
became public uh and the other one
was reactivation of latent DNA viruses
uh um shingles being a notable example
um and uh so there's a number of these
large herpes-like DNA viruses that exist
in our bodies for most of us
cytomegalovirus is another one
Epstein-Barr virus is a major one
and generally your T cells keep these
guys you can think of it as Pandora's
Box keeps the lid shut
um by you know T Cell suppression
and if you if you pull that suppression
off the top pops open and and all the
nasties fly out of Pandora's Box I think
is a good way to think about these
latent DNA viruses and it was clear that
that was happening after the Jab
uh it's it's one of the major it appears
now to be one of the major causes of the
kind of
shorter term short to intermediate term
uh long coveted symptoms particularly
Epstein-Barr virus
uh so that's what I was referring to now
uh
um fast forward to yesterday or the day
before
uh when uh Veritas dropped this third
video uh from Dr Walker uh I assume now
formerly uh Pfizer uh uh direct
worldwide director of mRNA vaccine or
mRNA strategies uh
in which he talks about the uh
hypothalamic uh pituitary gonadal axis
um
that what he's basically saying there is
that Pfizer believes that the menstrual
irregularities are really kind of the
tip of the iceberg and that this thing
is damaging a fundamental aspect of your
endocrine system your endocrine system
controls your energy controls your sex
drive it controls all kinds of
development it controls your mental
state whether you're depressed or
excited or whatever it controls your
digestion I mean it's your endocrine
system is hugely important and uh it you
know endocrine abnormalities can be
associated with cardiac problems uh and
uh they can absolutely they are
absolutely endocrine fluctuations uh
impact on your immune function
so now now we have in addition to the
huge laundry list we already had of
potential causes you know in terms of
the pathophysiology for why we're seeing
these
uh immunologic suppression phenotypes
particularly the more people get jabbed
uh but now we have another one which is
the damage to the hypothalamic pituitary
uh adrenal axis
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell